الروسية ها هي تستهدفها اليوم
فكيف سيكون الموقف الغربي من
كما تتنفسون. اوكرانيا التي وعدت
الغرب بعدم استهداف الاراضي
الجزائر وذلك باستقطاب الناشطة
المدانة باحكام قضائية جزائرية
اميرة بوراوي من تونس. فماذا لو
عاد معتذرا يا اهل الجزائر?
اليابان. وسعيا لمواجهة اطماع
الصين العسكرية في اسيا بدأ
قد ادانت هجوم المستوطنين على
ممتلكات الفلسطينيين في نابلس
العالم. لكن هنالك يتحضر لمواجهة
التنين الصيني. نعم انها
اجراءات لمنع تكرار الاعتداءات
الفلسطينيين. بينما كانت واشنطن
المبعوث الامريكي هادي عمرو يصل
نابلس ويقول انهم سيتخذون
وفق وكالة بلومبرج. وهو ما يمكن
ان يساعد بكين على زيادة مخزون
التخصيب الى الصين خلال الفترة
ما بين سبتمبر وديسمبر الماضيين
الرؤوس الحربية النووية بنحو
اربعة اضعاف في السنوات الاثنتي
المنطقة. الاحداث والتطورات.
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
الجوية. حيث كشفت وزارة الدفاع
التيوانية عن رصد تسع عشرة
للصين وذلك بتصدير ما من سبعة
اضعاف كمية اليورانيوم عالي
الصدد تحولت جزيرة يوناكوني
المعروفة بالطبيعة المسالمة
لقاعدة عسكرية تضم رادارات تراقب
تحركات الصين العسكرية في
عشرة المقبلة. فيا لها من بوادر
خطيرة لصراع نووي يمكن ان ينهي
يقول ان اطرافا فرنسية وجهت ضربة
لباريس لمحاولة افشال التقارب مع
مطالبة تل ابيب بمحاسبة
المسئولين عن العنف. انتم تكذبون
ارونا عقوباتكم يا هؤلاء حرب
الرقائق تتواصل. وفي اطار تعاطي
الجيش الياباني اجراء تعديلات
على عقيدته العسكرية. وفي هذا
الى امريكا. ومن معارك اشباه
الموصلات الى حرب الاختراقات
لتزود صناعة السلاح الروسية
بالرقائق الدقيقة واشباه
ادارة بايدن مع الملف الذي عاد
للواجهة مجددا ضمن نطاق الامن
الشركات الصينية والافراد الذين
ينتهكون العقوبات المفروضة على
لكن وبرغم التهديد العقوبات
الدولية فان الصين تتجاهلها
بانظمة الرادار للاستشعار عن بعد
واقمار مراقبة لمراقبة جميع دول
الاوكراني فالاول هو زالنسكي
والاخر هو درعه الواقي وحارسه.
القومي، الولايات تعمل على نقل
صناعة اشباه الموصلات التايوانية
مقاتلة تابعة للقوات الجوية
الصينية في منطقة الدفاع الجوي
الموصلات. وهو الامر الذي تفعله
تركيا كذلك بحسب وكانهم يقولون
روسيا مضيفا انه اذا قدمت الصين
مساعدات عسكرية لروسيا فسيؤدي
ذلك الى مشكلة في علاقات بكين مع
دول العالم. فعن اي مشكلة يتحدث
الاقمار الصناعية من الدول فهي
تمتلك عشرين قمرا صناعيا منذ ما
التيواني. لننتقل الى ما هو
اعظم. فها هي روسيا ترد الدين
يا له من سخاء حاتمي يا ابناء
العم سام. وهنا يفاجئ رئيس فاجنر
هنا وزير الخارجية الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن يتوعد باستهداف
الضيافة الامريكية لاوكرانيا
امريكا تطلب مقابل تلك الضيافة.
زلانسكي. الصين في خضم المعارك.
انتهى عهد وحان وقت المواجهة.
ليس فيلما هوليوديا بل هي
استراتيجية جديدة لحماية
انه الرجل الذي يقف خلف رئيس
اوكرانيا في كل المحافل. وهذا
يقارب العام ونصف العام. مشيرا
الى امتلاكها اقمارا صناعية تعمل
زلانسكي. هنا يحمي يا للعجب!
انهما نسختان من الرئيس
الولايات المتحدة. بقوله ان
فاجنر ليست بحاجة لشراء صور
الاسلحة الامريكية التي يتم
ارسالها اليها وبعد ان انتهت
الخارجية الامريكية وفق قوله.
ومن طباخ بوتين الى نسخة
نحو الحرب الاوكرانية. لتأتي
الضربة للاوكران من واشنطن هذه
بينما تؤجج الحرب في اوكرانيا
على حد وصفه. وهنا نعود قليلا
العالم باستخدام اقمارها
الصناعية بما في ذلك وزارة
سيليست والاندر انه يتوجب
اوكرانيا البدء في دفع ثمن
المرة وذلك بتأكيد مساعدة وزير
الدفاع الامريكي للشؤون الدولية
تتماشى مع نهج موسكو مشيرا الى
ان المعاني الدقيقة في الاقتراح
ان الصين لا يمكن ان تلعب دورا
مزدوجا عبر تقديم مقترحات للسلام
من قدرات روسيا العسكرية حيث لم
تستخدم موسكو بعد الى جزءا يسيرا
ليأت الرد من وزير الخارجية
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن الذي قال
بينما يكشف الامريكان الحقيقة
هنا. حيث اكدت وزيرة الجيش
الامريكية كريستين جورميث ان
واشنطن يجب الا تتهور في التقليل
ستولتنبرج? هل بعد ان تصبح
اوكرانيا رمادا? يا ذلك الطويل.
الامها لتدفع صاحبها الى الكشف
عن الام جرحه. هنا الرئيس
من قدراتها الجوية والبحرية
والسبرالية وفق وكالة نوفوستي.
الناتو ولكن على المدى الطويل.
اذا متى سيكون هذا الانضمام يا
الولايات المتحدة الى حين استماع
واشنطن الى موقف موسكو. فهل حان
مهمة. اضاف ان روسيا لن تستأنف
المشاركة في معاهدة نيو ستورت مع
وقت الاستماع للروس ايها
الامريكان ام ان للحرب بقية?
ديمتري بيسكوف مصرحا ان خطة
الصين لتسوية الازمة الاوكرانية
الاوكراني زلينسكي يقول ان
المعركة محتدمة في محيط باخموت
التي تحاول روسيا الاستيلاء
عليها منذ اشهر وان الوضع صعب
له قوات كييب للاشهر القادمة هل
سترفع رايتها البيضاء معلنة لفظ
القادمة ستكون ناشطة للغاية
وستحدد مسار الاحداث. بينما يشدد
انفاسها الاخيرة في باخموت الحرب
لا ترحم. وكلما طالت ايامها زادت
الى ارض المعارك في اوكرانيا.
حيث اكدت كييف ان الثلاثة الاشهر
هناك. فما كل هذا اليأس يا هذا
ليمد الامين العام للنايتو ينس
ومن اصداء المعارك الى مبادرة
السلام. حيث خرج المتحدث باسم
تلتومبيرج الاوكراني بالامل.
بقوله ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في
مدينتي سلوفيانسك وكرماتورسك
الاستراتيجيتين. فما الذي تخطط
الجيش الروسي الخناق على قوات
اوكرانيا في باخموت. لينطلق منها
تستهدفان البنية التحتية
الروسية. لتبدأ اجراءات الرد.
اجريت على منظومات الدفاع الجوي
بفرقاطة ميركل العسكرية الجديدة
للبلاد بكل الوسائل الضرورية بعد
ان كان عمدة موسكو قد اعلن عن
التابعة للجيش. رد بوتين لم
ينتهي حيث وقع الرئيس الروسي
والحاق الضرر بمن كانوا خلف
تحليق الطائرات المسيرة. لنعد
ذلك كانت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
قد اعلنت اسقاط مسيرتين كانتا
حقوق الانسان وغيرها وذلك ردا
على تحركات الغرب ضد موسكو وهنا
مرسوما لتعليق العمل بميثاق مجلس
اوروبا حول قمع الارهاب وحماية
الظهور. هنا المسيرات الاوكرانية
تواصل التسلل للاجواء الروسية،
دليل على تحضير بوتين للرد تحت
ستار الارهاب. والهدف الانتقام
ورئيس فاجنر يفجرها. نحن نراقب
واشنطن من السماء. وساحة حرب
يزعج الصين. الرئيس الفرنسي
للجزائر ويعلن عن ندمه، وواشنطن
اسقاط مسيرة اوكرانية اخرى في
مدينة كورونا شرق موسكو. وخلال
وموسكو ترد الدين النووي
للصينيين. واجراء عسكري ياباني
الروسي الى اهمية الرد على كل
التهديدات وحماية الامن القومي
حيث اعلنت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
عن نجاح الاختبارات الاخيرة التي
وللمرة الثانية يتم اسقاط مسيرة
اوكرانية موسكو. هناك دعا الرئيس
مجددا طائرات كييف تحلق فوق
العاصمة الروسية وبوتين يرد. نحن
تذر الملح على الجرح الفلسطيني.
روسيا تتحضر لرد قوي. الحرب تسلك
منحى اخر فقد دقت ساعة الحسم
والرايات البيضاء اوشكت على
جديدة بين الروس والامريكان على
حدود روسيا الخارجية الامريكية
ذلك?
تتوعد الرئيسين الصيني والتركي.
والسبب دعم بوتين من تحت الطاولة
الراية البيضاء وحلف الناتو يعلن
ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في
الحلف. والاستخبارات الاوكرانية
تستنسخ الرئيس الاوكراني والهدف
في باخموت والمدينة على وشك
السقوط. فهل هذا مؤشر لرفع
نعلم من ارسلها وسنرد ولن يمر
بسلام. والزينسكي المعارك طاحنة